emmanuel or we we can go ahead and
can introduce you now if you're ready
okay well welcome everyone to the second
day of the learning and testing in high
dimensions workshop
um we're very lucky to have emmanuel
ebay today who will tell us about
learning and testing for gradient
descent
okay thank you very much and thank you
for the introduction to
so i think i tried to adapt to the
theme of the workshop and essentially
what i'll tell you is
instances where we use testing to get
door bounds what we can descend on the
neural networks i'll first tell you
about how to get those lower bound for
general networks and i'll define these
and then i'll give you an application in
one
special case for how special algorithm
and easily compare on some
graph testing problem so first i'll
define what i mean by gdsd
et cetera so gd sgd with parameter n
here refers to the mini batch size so
the setting is you get your
net initialization w0 i'll discuss next
what how this is uh
what kind of initialization is allowed
you have your loss function your
sequence of weights
and then you integrate the visual
recursion of the std
you update the weight with here the
gradient loss and
the setting is that you get cam fresh
samples of each time step
okay there are iid from this
distribution px
and um and this notation here the same
is the empirical distribution of these
and fresh samples so this is uh this
expectation is exactly doing the
empirical average over this uh first
branch
okay so you integrate this at the
capital t time
and we produce a function which shall be
more typically f
of w at time capital t
all right so that's for the htv now for
the type of neural networks that we
allow
i guess the upwards we're thinking is uh
rather than
trying to model uh what's allowed or not
in terms of architecture is the idea to
be connected
is it which is not necessarily the most
relevant is it cnn
or something more fancy with the
combination of these we will essentially
go to the extreme
and just assume that uh we have like
networks so this is simply any kind of
our architecture that we want
so it has to have polynomial size
okay so the number of edges must be
pointing in the input dimension so
everything that i'm talking about is
going to be polynomial in the
input dimension and which is without the
dimension of the axis
that we fit to the network and
for the positive part is going to be
just the new network is going to be some
directed graph with some linearity for
the negative results it can be in fact
any differentiable model
and then for the initialization it can
be a general but it has to be a valid
initialization which means
you have to come up with initialization
time you can shift and do something
crazy
uh but okay and of course it has to be
not dependent on the data
for training and testing and also it has
to be administered to the target
function
although it may use some prior
hypothesis class or some reliability
assumption
i'll discuss so what are the learning
requirements
uh so i'm gonna work in the boolean
settings so the data is just binary
vectors of dimension n
the labels there's two classes plus
minus one
px as i said earlier is the protein
distribution of the inputs
and then we'll have a subset of
functions we have this class
or sometimes we work with a particle
distribution function
and what we will ask in either cases is
that we have balanced classes so
the two labels plus one minus one are
essentially
appearing slowly half for the margin
and now uh the learning requirement well
when we work with the
setting where we are given the fair
distribution for the input for the
function for the target function
we'll say that an algorithm has an edge
of alpha
so an algorithm is something that
produces a nets
and this depends on of course the
samples
and whatever randomness that person may
use
and so the obtaining an edge of alpha
means that
your version produces a level um on a
new fresh sample
x that is incorrect compared to the true
label
is the property which is
[Music]
okay so that's the the requirement and
this is uh the learning for a payoff
distribution because i'm picking
my probability here of course
gravity over the samples that you use
for training but also
um averaging over the x that is the new
first sample and also averaging over the
function f
drawn from my class okay so that's a
typical uh learning version essentially
average speed learning version
and of course okay let me first define
the other one the other one is the more
classic one
where you have learning for a class and
of the function and
you get the learning with an alpha if
this time i'm going to put the worst
case over the
function in the class and over the
distribution on this
same requirement and of course if you
fail at learning
in the first condition here then you
also failed at learning the second
condition so if
for some choice of p x and p f to fail
then uh for some alpha then you also pay
for the second requirement
now the choice of alpha intense the
weakest one
is when you only get a volume knob uh
edge so something that is not
exponentially small
in which case you could better be that
at the beginning here this was already
something which is for
sub uh and uh you can have a constant
edge with
a weak learning and you can have a an
edge which gets as
close as you want to run and that will
be strong learning or
fact and i put a bar on the back here
because
having excellent events but here i'm i'm
joining them by putting the single
quality
okay but this is essentially this is
equivalent to that
okay so last slide of definitions
is it's a bit heavy but then we should
be set
let's first define what i call poly std
and
so this is the class of function for
which there exists an initialization of
the nets
which depends only on the class of
function
and it has to be fully timed so in
particular the net has to be coincide
and then there's a loss function so that
if you run sdd with all primary
polynomials so that's the number of
times that has to be polynomial
and there's this snr here that i will
explain in a second
then you achieve and this is the same
requirement i have on the previous slide
you achieve
this edge of alpha in the worst case
now i'm going to define the exact same
thing for gd instead of sgd
except that now i'm adding the supreme
over all the n more than one where
remember that
n is the backside in other words i'm
forcing
for the the class 40 gb i'm forcing to
succeed with m that could be as large as
you want
in particular infinity okay
and then the third class is going to be
cody sq
that's the class of function for which
there's just an sq algorithm that
uses totally many queries of corey snr
such that again you produce the same
requirement as before
and now let me tell you what is this snr
that shows up in all this listing
so when you look at the
when you look at the the queries that
you make in 0 so if you call this the
function gp
what you do when you run sdd is you take
an expectation of something
gt that depends on x and some
the target function and
and what you have here is this empirical
distribution over the center
now if you do statistical queries what
you will have instead here is an
expectation which is
over the entire population distribution
so it could be expectation of x over
dx of some qt function
and you have plus minus some precision
sigma
that is due to the fact that you don't
want to work in a setting where
the queries can have arbitrary magnitude
and the noise can have it can be
arbitrarily small
so what i call the snr is precisely the
ratio between the magnitude that your
service can take so there will be plus
minus c
so c is the range of qt divided by sigma
this is going to be the snr of your
variables
i don't want to derive results that are
going to explode infinite precision
sometimes
so that's well defined in sq and in fact
typically in sqc is what we want so one
over sigma is the
the snr um and here it will have the
same the output that the simplest
vrgb will ask that the ratio between the
range of the rhythm of the loss
and the noise that you had has to be
polynomial so you don't want to work
with infinite precision when you run
your hdb
anything like this so that's what this
snr refers to
that shows up in all
you work with polynomial parameters also
for the ratio of magnitude
precision numbers again the last class
is the kodi ag and this is the class
where you don't have any constraints
just there exists an algorithm that runs
in polytime
that uses fully many samples such that
you achieve your
original point so this is a
this is the the four class you would
expect that the last one is the most
generic one
uh s2 is the next and then between those
two
naively perhaps uh gdu was largely
matched and shouldn't hurt
but the results are perhaps you know
slightly surprising and they are as
follows
so first of all there is a equivalence
between the class
uh sgd for esd and uh
so you have that
so you have that for any alpha that you
fix between zero and one
then uh whatever you can do employee
time is some algorithm you can also do
by running lcd
on such a poly so that's
this university result
uh and then you have the separation
between polysgd
and the bose polyester or pvgd
and the separation is uh in the so the
values that i have in here
i say that uh here you can have the
strongest requirement and you hear the
weekend so
there are functions that you can learn
with arbitrary uh
with an edge which is obviously one with
sdd
that you cannot even learn this
polynomial edge is either s p or d
um and these are the functions that will
uh discuss in a second
and also we know that these two are in
fact the same for egd import sql
[Music]
okay so any questions on this
i'll i'll then start to talk about it
and can you explain again
why is um so sgd is not
sq that's what you're saying here yeah
there's a separation
there's a separation between lgbtq
super intuitively why why is that this
separation
it's because sgd if you're not forced to
uh take averages over the entire batches
or very large matches you can take a
single sample at the time
so that will allow you when you are in
this framework of uh
poly networks for initialization will
allow you to run
algorithm like uh gaussian illumination
which you can do with ge or sql devices
so it's a single sample power that
that gives you the edge okay exactly
right okay so i
now tell you a bit uh where testing
comes in
it's for the lower bounds so the lower
bound looks like this the property that
you get
the the the wrong label is your
algorithm uh
output at time t this is uh remember
that's what you get when you run
uh resource dbm for
two times step and uh
you don't get the right label with the
property which is lower bound by half
which is
because the the classes are balanced
this is the tree of the value
minus this ratio of these two terms the
gf is the joint flow and cp is the first
predictability
and they are defined like this so the
jump rope
is going to be the power series of the
expected gradient norm when you go
through your thumb steps
divided by one over sigma which remember
is the noise position
the noise lines for standard division
and then
so yeah let me first cover both and then
i'll give back to you
and the cross productivity is some sort
of average uh
notion of statistical dimension it's the
correlation you get between two
functions that are sampled from your
class
when you take for the measure in the
correlation you take the empirical
distribution
okay so let's look at the joint tool
first
um if you want to upgrade this quickly
what you can do is simply say
okay there's the one over sigma that is
here
i'm gonna pronounce this by t for the
number of times steps and then i'm just
gonna open
each summon here by the number of the
dimension of this vector so this is a
the gradient so it doesn't dimension the
number of edges in the graph
in your neural nets and then the
magnitude that
each component can have which is valid
by c and c could be n to the 100 is just
the fact that you don't have infinite
magnitude
and so this thing will be going and
when you work in this poly std setting
where all parameters must be foreign and
and now if you look at the the cross
spread
if you write how this cross square is uh
is expressed in terms of the the
particular n which is the size of the
batch so it is like one over n
plus you can ignore this first one or
some constant plus the cp
infinity which is just the same notion
that when you take the population
uh distribution for completing your
correlation between two
typical functions this quantity here can
be small
it can definitely be growing faster than
any polynomial
that's for example the case if you take
k parties
where k is growing with
so clearly because example must be
polynomial at most and
because the cross spread uh infinitely
can be
uh super polynomial if you take your n
here which is a large enough polynomial
then this quantity will smash down the
juncture and this tends to happen
okay so that's the reasoning why an
argentine will
hurt you in some cases where this
sleeping pinky
is going to be very small but if you
don't do large m
if you speak with n is equal to one like
in std
then this term here is going to stick to
one and so the cross spread cannot be
smaller
and then this bound becomes loose and it
doesn't tend to happen
and in fact then the second result here
is going to tell you that there's a
reason for this is because with sgd you
can
emulate any algorithm as opposed to
easily okay so where is the
testing coming it's coming in the
following way
when you try to show that the output of
gda is not going to succeed the
strategy is that you compare how does
gdp behave when you swing on two data so
w subscript f represents
the algorithm so the weights that are
are obtained by gd when you train
with the right labels here with the
right
data labels and then w subscript star
is going to reference to uh the
evolution of gde
or a cd when you train with a random
label
here so that means you don't get uh you
get giant
uh radonicals half tables
and the strategy is to show that the
total variation distance
between the distribution of the waves
is going to be vanishing uh if b is not
too large so in other words we cannot
distinguish
the algorithm output and the true on the
journey
and therefore by the typical variation
bound the project we get the right label
is a true guy here or if you get the
right level with the tongue guys here
must be
downloaded by the tv this guy here must
be half because it's
just uh independent of the of the two x
so you cannot
hope to predict with gen data better in
half
and if this guy is vanishing when t is
not too large then
you get your lower bound let's say that
you cannot generate the right now okay
so
now from there it becomes uh information
periodic inequalities and
that's why i like this approach because
now you just have to
down the tv so this can be here
and and here the i think the
basic uh rules that i use is that um
for the tv you can write it uh as uh so
the way i use the formula that i use for
here is just to put the definition that
this is the supremum
of the measure of the two measures for
any events
or you can think of it as the
l1 norm of the of the distribution which
allows you to use the triangular
inequality in the tv
or you can think about it as the
you can think about it as the best error
when you try to
you try to like what this is testing
between the two measure
and in particular this implies that the
data position inequality of the tv
which is that um variable
it's always greater than tv between a
function of this human variable
okay so this is what you use triangular
inequality using this definition and
that was inequality allows you to show
that you have the several activity of tv
over the time steps when you run within
this end which is an
important property and then to bound
each of this term here
what you do is uh you typically upper
bound the tv
so you can either do it by programming
with the l which is the
thin screen pointing and then the kl
itself is going to be
bounded by the child square
the distance between the message and uh
typically when you want to bound the
clear the total variation distance
it's convenient to go to the tail uh
divergence because
you can have chain rules uh but
eventually if you want to express those
terms
if you want to show something to zero
you always end up by proving that the
casper equal to zero because the chi
squared
is in fact uh this becomes tight
inequalities
uh when those uh measures become close
to each other
so when you want to pull the tv goes to
zero you end up with a cash flow term
that is going to have some productive
factors and then you can
give you crucifix and this is how you
end up with things that are correct in
terms of this form
and the cautious box is what end up with
having two terms like that
so obviously i i i only wanted to cover
the rough ideas without giving the
details but
essentially this is the flavor of how
you end up with a bound that looks like
this
by manipulating this information
okay so now uh for the last ten minutes
i'll tell you
about the uh some uh application of
lower bound
uh when you don't have a fully
initialization but the random
initialization
of enrollments and uh here is the
example so it's back to the good old
stochastic
model uh you want to distinguish so you
want to decide
whether you have two classes for your
data it's the data i say there are never
swinging venom graph fighter nr
or it's going to be an sbm with 5 or eq
so that means
you patch two later swinging models and
energy vertices
and you connect them the globe with
and we're gonna ensure that r is the
average of two plus two by two
so that these two graphs have the same
edge density okay so
the goal is going that uh i will select
one of these two graph
is probably half from class 1 and plus 2
and you have to decide
where it came from is the probability of
error that is better than half so you
want to get
half minus half the omega of 1 so
the head has to be on the output
uh so that's the goal and so that the
weak learning requirements
and uh because the tv as we just said
before
is half minus half the quality of error
of the optimal test between the t major
then
then what we want in order to be able to
succeed in guessing
where the graph comes from is prohibited
in half is that the total version
distance
has to be bounded away from zero between
the two measure
of the two random graph models
okay so this has been studied now for
some time and
we know that you can succeed in doing
this even in the sparse regime when t is
equal to a by
n and q is equal to b by n
and as long as the a minus b
divided by two square is more than the a
plus b
w by two which is the cash threshold
then this total rising distance is going
to be done away from zero
so you can solve this testing problem
any questions on the setting
soon i will uh i will also tell you how
uh you could try to solve this problem
with a gradient descent when you
sampled from each class but for now it's
the one side problem
okay so we have two more slides
um now uh how do you solve this uh so
this was a little version bound gets
believed in this regime but how do you
solve this with
some tests with some algorithm uh so one
thing you can do is simply
count cycles just for moments and um
and what you have is that in the error
city model when b is my average degree
here so
d is going to be art and n and
it's uh it's remember that it has to be
the a plus b by two
because we have this balance equation
here
uh if you are in the inner edge of any
case this is the number of
n cycles so if you count the number of
time cycles
then it's going to be four to this
in your listening model it grows
exponentially with v
divided by two ends in the lengths of
the cycles and this is the volume
around that's the mean uh
if you count the number of end cycles in
the sdn then
what you get is the same dominant term
the same perturbation
but now you have this term here which is
due to the community
presence in the graph so as you can see
if this quantity m minus v by 2
is more than the quantity value here
which is a plus b by 2
square roots then in fact this is going
to dominate the situation
here and therefore i can distinguish
these two quantities
you just need to take m that grows
slowly like for example
log log n and then you will be able to
distinguish the humidity models by
counting on cycles
okay another way to approach this
problem is through
spectral algorithm if you look at the
matrix the adjacency matrix a of the
graph
let's look first at the expectation of a
then what you have here is an eigenvalue
of zero of the eigenvalue
of multiplicity n minus one and then an
eigenvalue of
uh d of multiplicity one
uh in expectation the block model you
have the eigenvalue zero is multiplicity
n minus two because there is a then two
matrix now
still the d for the parallel from the
news as before and then
here you have the a minus b by 2 which
is the eigenvalue of the
communities corresponding to plus one
and this guy and minus one in the second
condition
okay that's in expectation if now you go
to the true
matrix a that you see in the one-sided
problem
then you could hope that the belt is
going to break here into something
that does not overspeed on this two
eigenvalues that don't move much
and then you can still use the second
eigenvalue to detect the communities
but we know that this is not true in
this class regime a doesn't work
however if you use b which is an
unbacktracking operator
then this will be true
the picture is in 2d because it's a
complex value but essentially
you do have that the second largest
second value uh
corresponds to an eigenvector that is
close to the the one that uh
gets the two okay so
we without the adversary before we do
the adversary case
we know that both the method of moments
and the number of
non-backtracking operators get to the
optimal threshold for this problem so
it's a problem that is solvable
okay now i'm just going to add something
to make the print more interesting is we
have an adversary
and the adversary can do the following
you can take your graph before i
so i i draw from either classroom class
2
the adversary comes you can modify order
login edges in the graph
and then it shows this modification to
you and then you have to decide where
the
graph comes from so
what happens here is that if you do
this adversary both the method of
moments and the method of uh
non-backlighting break and they break
because
the adversary can put a click uh inside
one of the group for example so it can
even be a mountain adversary that
doesn't
only add edges inside the cursor and
um and then you would create this the
second value will now be deleted by
an eigenvector that is localized
again this is true for the uh
the number shifting method and what
happens for the moments is so that the
counts become completely disruptive
okay so now we know that there is a way
to get around this it's the power
powering method it's the
the you take your graph and you add an
edge between every vertex and distance r
so you complete the graph so the
operator of uh
graph firing is this matrix one
so you just complete the graph by
connecting every vertex of distance
at least our underground let's move on
this is going to get to the optimum
threshold then it's also going to be
robust to this adversary
so again the problem with an adversary
is not something which is impossible but
we know at least one algorithm and uh
and there's another one so we did it
with graphql here's another one which is
very good that has been done
also here um so it is possible to guess
between the
two models with the adversary uh what's
interesting is if you try to use a
now uh gd and what you do is that you
sample from um you get many samples from
class one
put them quite on a number of symbols
for class one same form class two and
you transition for the time
then we believe that it's optimum
without the adversary so that means uh
i don't think it's proof that we believe
it will go down to the optimal threshold
however there is one versus ring that's
my last uh phrase
uh that is going to break dvd and it's
not the same
kind of abstraction right here here what
the adversary would do is uh it will
take uh
all the cycles of lengthy which is less
than model again
and it will break those cycles
and if you do that you break all these
short cycles and then we believe that
uh you can still succeed with power
spectrum that
has been improved but we believe that
gdp will not no longer be able to
uh classify with string burn and the
technique
we can show you some special case not
and we would like to show you some
arbitrary id uh initialization
uh but we can show you something on
special case but we deliver this to it
for any ideas version of
so emmanuel there's a question from joe
nieman who's asking
can you comment on what happens if you
allow more than
log n changes or how this changes as a
number of edges
yes so uh for uh
so in here what you can tolerate
for the number of edges for the
adversary is uh essentially
end to the hexagon for excellence moving
up so you can generate uh
quite a bit more than the login that i
mentioned so i just took login
as a as an adversary budget that was uh
below what you can tell they wait for
this type of method uh
here i think that as long as you give it
any k which is growing
as long as you manage to break down all
the the shorter cycles of lengthy
for any at any growing rate then then
you would actually
have g that is in trouble on a random id
initialization
does it answer the question
i don't see the chat but maybe
um this was in the q a yes joe says that
yes thank you
great thanks
so i guess if there's no other questions
or we can continue in the gather town
later
um but yeah thanks very much emmanuel
for the time
thank you